this is just factory setting thinking
this is just stuff that you get from the
media you get from culture it's like
Democrat good Republican bad Democrats
care about poor people Republicans care
about money there's a million of these
nonsensical things and all that is is
factory settings that through culture
through state education through all
these things that is where we all sort
of baseline start it's your job to
modify your system to something that you
like and that's that's what the way you
behave with the world should be as well
I'm joined by Dave Rubin host of the
Rubin report and author of don't burn
this book Dave welcome to show Chris
it's good to be with you we are doing
this across the pond over these digital
waves that everybody is now stuck on we
thought we thought we were too online
before this thing then Corona comes and
this is the only way we can do anything
I want to be more online no yeah first
first things first
Dave why is your book dedicated to Ben
Affleck
this is either gonna go down as a
brilliant marketing ploy or Affleck and
the Affleck Empire will have me
destroyed we should know the answer in
the next couple days but I devoted the
book to Ben Affleck because I tell the
story in the book about how appliqu
actually believe it or not was was a key
piece to my political awakening because
you may remember Ben Affleck was on Real
Time with Bill Maher when sam Harris the
the neuroscientist and really mindful
thinker was on to talk about his book
waking up a guide to spirituality
without religion and they started
talking about how you have to separate
ideas from people meaning we should be
able to criticize ideas and that doesn't
mean that you should be bigoted towards
people and they were talking about in a
religious context so in this case you
should be able to criticize the set of
ideas that is Islam but what you
wouldn't want to do is be bigoted
towards Muslim people and by the way of
course you should be able to criticize
any set of ideas whether it's the set of
ideas that make up a religion Judaism
Christianity whatever it is or the set
of rules that make up a political party
or a set of rules that make up you know
uh basketball rules anything like that
Sam calmly laid this out and Bill Maher
sort of backed him on this and next
thing you know Affleck was huffing and
puffing and screaming and in effect he
called Bill Maher and Sam Harris gross
and racist and this is about five years
now five years ago and in that very
moment I saw exactly what I had been
thinking was wrong with the left exactly
what I've been thinking was wrong with
the progressives in in stark daylight I
had had these thoughts for a while you
know you're just calling everybody
racist
you're calling everybody a bigot you're
always morally right and with this
indignation and anger but suddenly to
see it turned on this mild-mannered
neuroscientist who I didn't even know
who he was at the time and then Bill
Maher who really was the standard bearer
of the left at least in an American
context he's been our basically our
biggest most outspoken lefty the guy
gave Obama a million bucks for his
re-election I mean he has fought every
progressive issue you know I mean and
constantly rallying against Republicans
and then a flick says you're gross and
racist and then the next level of it was
watching the media just parrot that
because Affleck said saying just because
a Hollywood star said something next
thing you know Vox and BuzzFeed and
HuffPo and all the usual suspects are
suddenly saying that Bill Maher and
their Sam Harris guy that they're
racists and and that was really one of
the I'll a out three key points of
waking up going from say woke to awake
in my book and that was one of them so I
feel that I owe Ben Affleck even though
we've never met thanks Ben
yeah yeah interesting that sometimes
even though we know things we need quite
a symbolic inflection point to happen so
that it causes something right so my
favorite quote of the whole book is
right in that section and I'm just going
to read the passage out now so you're
talking about the particular way in
which Ben puts his words across which is
compelling to a very particular type of
watcher viewer listener fund this tactic
is typical of people who don't know what
they're talking about instead of having
a solid argument based on fact they
simply moralize their way through life
shooting people down and throwing terms
around as a distraction their
over-the-top emotion is enough to
convince unthinking people on a base
level they've won because it appears as
if they're morally right man I really
really love that I thought that's a lot
of sense making going on there yeah
thanks well you know it's interesting so
let's say this is Chris this is the
first time we've met right now let's say
I said something in just a moment that
was you kind of thought was like a
little bigoted or odd or racist or
something in a normal
situation the way functioning people
behave you wouldn't immediately call me
a racist you might follow up and ask me
something to go maybe I misunderstood
you or are you sure that's what you
meant to say or something like that but
what Affleck did and you know this is
also partly the way TV condenses
everything and makes everything stupider
that these segments are so short that
you end up sort of becoming like the
worst version of yourself which is why
so much in cable news is just you know
hacking at each other and pounding each
other but in effect in a normal argument
if you met somebody at a bar and they
said something it would take like a
couple beats before you called them
racist but Affleck the fact that that
was the initial thing that he went to it
shows you what that thing is it doesn't
mean you know what you're talking about
but it seems like you know what you're
talking about
and unfortunately for a huge swath of
the American population but I know you
guys are dealing with this in the UK and
it's and it's a worldwide phenomenon
actually acting as if you're morally
outraged has replaced thinking so that's
really what I was trying to get to there
and the fact that it was coming from an
a-list actor in the rest of it and what
you said earlier is right we all walk
around we're sort of thinking things and
what if you're a thinking person you're
walking through the world you try to
piece together a cohesive worldview
sometimes though you need the moments
like that you need to see Batman call
somebody racist for the for the whole
thing to crystallize right you have red
took us Maurice the madness of crowds
right and this is one of the greatest
writers on earth as a matter of fact
when I was writing this book I was
reading the madness of crowds at the
same time and I have I have all of his
books and I was like man this guy knows
how to turn a phrase I mean you guys in
general that's what Americans are always
jealous of we've got crap weather but
we've got some some lovely vernacular
but you know so use you were worried
about I've opened the book we've
dedicated to Ben Affleck you know he
could have chosen a lot of other people
that weren't Ben but Douglas had Nicki
Minaj lyrics
so if he should get away with that I
reckon you can get away with next thing
next second most important thing before
we fully get into it what's your
favorite thing about Michael malleus
MELAS I mean malice I I call him the the
Willy Wonka of politics because he's
such an over-the-top brilliant thinker
that it is so hard to pigeonhole what he
really is thinking versus how he's using
trolling he's a brilliant wordsmith he's
one of the few people that I don't hate
on Twitter because I'll read something
of his and I'll go whoa that was clever
and then I'll have to read it three
hours later because I go man that was
even better than exactly he's just a
great thinker he's fearless he's staking
out positions that are extremely
politically incorrect in many ways yet
are sensible and that he thinks them
through and what I really love about him
is he's playing a long game here where
he he always says that concern what's
what's the line conservatism is just
left ISM at the at the speed limit
something like that I'm slightly
butchering it but really that he's
thinking about the world in a sort of
holistic way and also it's kind of being
fun about it and and trollee
I have you seen the hare purgatory that
your show has left him in I did see a
picture everyone's having hair problems
well not you yesterday this came out
yesterday yeah exactly so for the
listeners people are just listening
you're gonna have to imagine it but this
was the day after my flatmates shaved my
hair so I've usually got sort of curly
hair on top um yet so Michael did a
little bit of a streak in his hair to do
this tulsi gabbard look to come on your
show yeah and his plan was to grow it
out and cut it out but now he's in New
York locked down with no barbers or
hairdressers available and he's just
stuck in hair purgatory and he what's
this shriek in his hair and he says he's
tried every 1920s gents hairstyle
available and he's going through like
the side pas I like the slicked back and
trying to get in to do a man bun but you
won't you won't go for it he's looking
kinda bananas but it fits the overall
political low-key thing yet to put the
political okey so on to don't burn this
book why why did you write it well I
wrote it well it's interesting
I mean the absolute truth is you know
although I had been thinking about a
book for quite some time when I was on
tour with Jordan Peterson we were in
Ireland Ireland we were doing the Dublin
show that night and I got a call from my
agent and he said you know we're getting
all these offers for you to do a book do
you want to do a book and while I had
been thinking about it it's like once it
was presented to me then I was like
alright now I guess I got to do it you
know it's time to make the move and I'm
a firm believer that when things get
presented if you're roughly interested
in them you should take that opportunity
like take opportunities as life presents
them so when I sign the deal it was
originally why I left the left and I
talked about this right at the beginning
because sort of everybody had sort of
associated that phrase with me I did
that Prager you video it's got like 20
million views and I think that was the
idea like let's get Rubin to talk about
why he left the left and I started
writing that and then I was just kind of
like you know I've said all of this
before you know I think part of the
reason that people care about what I
what I do and what I talk about is that
everyone can sort of see how crazy the
left has gone you guys have a
particularly insane strain of it in the
UK by the way although your last
election you know hopefully tampered it
a little bit but I was ahead of the
curve on that like what I was saying
four years ago about the left is now
sort of mainstream thought and when I
was writing it I was like you know I
don't want to write a book that's just
about the stuff that I'm against meaning
I'm against leftism I'm against
collectivism and progressivism I want to
write a book about what I'm for so I
actually scrapped it and I had to talk
to to the agents and everybody just make
sure that they were okay with me doing
this cuz it wasn't the book that I
signed up for and we changed the title
and everything else and then what I
really realized was I want to show
people a little bit of an
autobiographical how I survived the
monster once you start actually speaking
up how do you get through the mob how do
you identify fake news how do you chart
a course that is sensible and
and also talk about the ideas that I
think are the correct ideas which are
the ideas of classical liberalism which
in a modern sense have much more to do
with libertarianism and even
conservatism then then well certainly
then progressivism and everything that
the that the Liberals from an American
perspective have I know you guys
actually have a much stronger tradition
when people say classical liberal you
guys have a much better understanding of
that where in America the word liberal
has just been completely mangled and
that's one of the things I'm trying to
clean up a little bit here yeah what
what is the difference between leftism
and liberalism classic liberalism give
us the roadmap yeah so so liberalism
classical liberalism is is very simple
to understand I mean the most important
thing is individual rights if you are a
member of any free society meaning
you're a citizen of any society whether
it's the UK whether it's the United
States whatever it is we have equal
rights for everybody that's it there is
no special treatment based on skin color
or gender or any of those things that we
have somehow become obsessed with equal
rights for everybody and then basically
lays a Fair economics that the
light-touch of government when needed is
is all that you need and that that is
basically the formula to allow people to
live with the greatest amount of liberty
and freedom so that they can in American
context pursue happiness right pretty
pretty sweet and by the way this is the
founding principle that the Constitution
was written on and the Declaration of
Independence was written on now in an
American perspective that sounds very
much like a libertarian and what I
always say is the only real difference
between a classical liberal and a
libertarian is if you were to take
libertarianism to its nth degree and
this is sort of like a malice type place
you would be disassembling the
government everywhere I love that
intellectually and by the way because
the coronavirus I think we're seeing so
many in efficiencies in government that
I think a lot of people I'm seeing
lefties right now wake up to all sorts
of things like why do we have federal
income tax because people need their own
money right now like these are really
super interesting things which is which
is pretty great actually but I would say
the difference between a libertarian and
a classical liberal is that the
classical
we'll seize a little more need for
government a little bit more so I do
believe government can we can have
public education I don't want it
exclusively I also want school choice
and charter schools and all sorts of
stuff but I do think the government has
some role in keeping the social cohesion
but at the same time I want most things
done by the states so I live in
California and unfortunately we have
super high taxes and the whole thing is
pretty inefficient and totalitarian but
I could move and that's a beautiful
thing I could move to Texas and maybe I
will wear it taxes are lower and maybe
the the people are a little more in line
with the types of things I think that's
a beautiful thing because if you don't
have states rights well if you don't
like it in one state well then you got
to leave the country so America was
really set up on this beautiful federal
system where there's an ongoing
experiment all the time so so
libertarianism and classical liberalism
it's very close except for those
marginal things of where the government
should get involved I would say then the
difference between classical liberalism
and conservatism at this point is that
generally conservatives have a little
more of a religious view of the world so
then on the some of the social issues I
think they get a little hung up but
actually not as much as they used to
because many conservatives now see gay
marriage as whether they're thrilled
with it or not for example they've just
let it be like there's really nobody
railing against it and I think most of
their fears turned out to be unwarranted
and then and then the difference really
which is your question between
liberalism classical liberalism and
progressivism is that progressivism
basically means the state should pretty
much do everything so whenever Bernie or
a Ossie or any of these people talk
about anything or Corbyn from your
perspective it's like they want the
state to pretty much do everything we
want free college for everybody we want
the state to tell businesses what they
can pay people there is nothing you know
have free health care for everyone of
course nothing's free that and then with
the problem with that is that once you
start if your starting point is the
state should do everything this top-down
thing I like bottom-up I like
individuals then can build a system I
don't like oh the system then has to
basically quash the individual the
with with leftism so you could take
something like the the minimum wage
which here in America there's this this
big debate should we have a $15 minimum
wage now I don't believe in a federal
minimum wage anyway because I believe in
competition and I know that I have a ton
of people that would love to work for me
people offer to work for me for free all
the time now I pay everybody that works
for me and we pay him quite well
actually but I don't think it's up to
the government to decide whether I pay
that person $13 an hour 15 or 20 now the
problem on the left is Bernie comes out
and says well I'm for $15 minimum wage
and then Rashidah to leave but
congresswoman here in the states comes
out and she says well I'm for a 20
minute twenty dollar minimum wage and
then it's like well I guess so because
you just made up a number why can't I
just make up a number and that's why the
government just grows because all
they're operating off of is how they
feel about any given thing that is
extremely different than saying I'm for
individual rights which is what
classical liberals and conservatives and
libertarians believe I want everyone to
be equal equal playing field it doesn't
mean that some people aren't born with
more it doesn't mean that some people
aren't luckier it doesn't mean that some
people won't work hard but those are all
things that that that's just the human
condition and the government has to get
out of the way as much as possible and I
think unfortunately just to wrap this up
really quick
the the progressives saw liberals
liberals that are nice and decent and
open because that the liberal mind
usually is those things and progressives
saw that and said we can get in here
there's a weak underbelly and let's get
into the system by basically destroying
liberalism and taking over the
Democratic Party and I think that's
basically what we've seen there are no
good liberals left I mean there's very
few it's like it's like the Jedi after
order 66 they've been they've been
scattered across the galaxy and hunted
down you know yeah yeah one of the
points that you brought up was about gay
marriage and I thought this was really
interesting what you mentioned was that
being liberal means being sufficiently
liberalism means being sufficiently
liberal to support gay marriage and also
sufficiently liberal to tolerate people
who opposed it yeah that on the surface
doesn't seem like a tremendously complex
point it again comes back to individual
sovereignty you are allowed to decide to
like and dislike what
is that you want and yet if someone was
to say I disagree with gay marriage and
you don't say bigoted racist xenophobic
homophobic you think that would be like
well you you it just doesn't doesn't
mesh right you know it doesn't seem to
have sense well that's that's where the
feelings thing should not be the thing
that we're governed by what we should be
governed by is that we're all treated
equally under the law that that is my
underlying principle behind everything
else that I would talk about so for
example I have had several guests in my
studio which as you know is in my house
I'm in my house right now
I have welcomed in people such as ben
shapiro who's an orthodox jew who by his
outlook on life his religious
perspective on life is against same-sex
marriage I have had Bishop Baron here
from the archdiocese in LA who from his
Catholic perspective is personally
against gay marriage I have had fruitful
honest conversations with them now
before gay marriage was passed we're
either one of them fighting for gay
marriage of course not but at the same
time gay marriage has now been passed
and I don't see either that either of
them trying to legislate it away so what
you have to understand in a free society
is there are going to be people who
disagree with you there are going to be
people who disagree with your lifestyle
on the rest of it but as long as they
don't take that onto your property as
long as they don't try to destroy your
job or your life or anything else then
actually you should relish in your
differences and the irony what what
right would I have to tell Ben Shapiro
an Orthodox Jew or Bishop Baron a
Catholic or a devout Muslim what right
would I have to say you must bend to my
will I don't want them to have that
power over me so I have to accept that I
don't have that power over them now I
think what you can do and by the way
I've said this to Ben many times that
what you can do is buy a think by being
a decent human being over time you can
show people that maybe some of their
views are a little bit backwards or I
don't even want to say backwards that
maybe there's some of some of there
traditional views maybe maybe the time
has passed on some of them or something
like that hops their views actually
don't align with their values anymore
and they've just grandfathered these old
views in by by way of well they were
here therefore I'll keep them going and
again what what what did we say right at
the start that inflection point perhaps
sometimes you can be that inflection
point well I think you're absolutely
right it's actually a really great point
so let's say somebody's values don't
quite match up with their views suddenly
or their political beliefs suddenly what
would be the best way to get them on
there on your side would it be to call
them a racist or would it be to continue
to talk to them continue to have that
conversation and then over time and this
is what I've said to Ben is Ben you know
when I'm 90 and you're 85 and we've done
this for 50 some odd years I suspect
you'll have come around to my position a
little more than I'll have come around
to your position he doesn't agree with
me I didn't like I bet you didn't agree
with that at the time but there's only
one way to find out and I'll also tell
you this you know there was a night when
when we were on tour with Jordan
Peterson and we did our second la show
and it's at the Orpheum and here in
downtown LA thousands of people who it
was one of our best shows and I brought
Ben on as a surprise guest so I go up
and I do about 10 minutes a lobster
jokes and getting everybody laughing and
then I bring Ben on Ben comes on he
brings a little cupcake with them
because you know there's there was this
meme about that he wouldn't bake me a
gay wedding cake as if I would want Ben
to bake me a cake anyway so he hands me
a cupcake he does an impression of
Jordan Peterson we do a little funny
banter back and forth couple videos get
out on Twitter and it was so interesting
because I'm in a room of 3,000 people
and everyone knows he has a traditional
view of marriage everyone knows that I'm
married to a man we get up there we're
having a great time there's mutual
respect everyone in the audience is
laughing cheering screaming it's great
couple clips go out on Twitter and
suddenly it's the tolerant progressives
calling me a self-hating gay and been a
homophobe and our audience a bunch of
white supremacists and it's like you
know I was just in that room and in that
room what America really is about is
what was experienced and you guys from
the outside while you tell us we're all
bigots and self haters and all the rest
of it
perhaps you might want to look in the
mirror so I think over the course of
time if you're a decent person you can
bring more people to your side and
unfortunately that's just really been
lost on the left I get it
I think this might be a small area
discrimination or perhaps a uk-wide one
although based on some of the stuff we
saw in the last general election maybe
not uk-wide but I have to say personally
is someone from the northeast of the UK
none of this stuff doesn't that we don't
hear words about there's no debate about
transgender bathrooms there's no
discussion about whether the gender pay
gaps this or the gender pay gaps that
like reading your book feels a lot like
a window into a world which doesn't
exist and I know it does exist that's
interesting it but it's not one that I
can can really relate to all that well
that'd be good I'd be interested to hear
through the people in the UK that are
listening tell me if I'm alone with this
right just because I really I spoke to
zubi I've spoken Douglas Murray I've
spoke a Andrew Doyle and you know these
I don't know whether there's certain
areas certain corners the internet
perhaps after this goes up I'll be just
fully feet-first into it we'll see who
will see who catches catches onto this
episode but you get my point right it's
interesting for me to watch and I'm
super glad that I'm the voyeur
in this rather than the person that's
that's it's getting stuck in um yeah I
hate to tell you you can never last as
the boy or too long like once you've
talked to dangerous Douglas Murray and
zubi and Andrew Doyle and me I mean
eventually you won't be on the voyeur
side of that but but I actually that's
inspiring what you just said actually
the idea nice knife that's exactly why
I'm here for me yeah well well there you
go I mean that but that is that is the
truth because look a lot of these bad
ideas about gender pronouns and
everyone's a bigot and all this stuff
it's not real other than it's pushed on
us by the mainstream media all the time
and the rest of it so when when Douglas
who I would say is fighting it in the in
the most brave way possible and has been
fighting it before everybody when he's
fighting it it's not that it
doesn't exist but it doesn't mean that
it's everyone it's a really loud yapping
dog that we finally have to just sort of
put in a cage and just say well you can
keep barking please to go out the back
in the woods doesn't it and just yeah I
need to segue here have you seen how
jacked Douglas Murray's got recently I
haven't I haven't seen Oh Dave everyone
that's listening right now going to
Douglas Murray's Twitter and try and
find some of the most recent photos of
him that guy has got jacked out of his
my he's just I don't know what he's been
doing using coronavirus preparation for
like I'm not even kidding I'm not
kidding you at all when we recorded he
died like a couple of glasses of wine
and just looked like a normal dude and
now he looks like a pro athlete I'm
honestly good I'm gonna saw I saw a
picture of him with some scruff I
thought you know not going on that's a
net you so he started he grew the beard
and then he's got jacked so that's it
right next next thing um why do people
need a road map to leave the left well I
can just leave my house or a football
team on my Jim I'm a business you know
like I can do what I want why do I need
a road map to leave the left because
unfortunately it's a lot easier to walk
out of your house and walk into the gym
than to leave an ideological echo
chamber what what these people have done
quite effectively is trick good people
who have very decent views which
probably you share many of they've
tricked them into thinking that they
shouldn't say what they think so when I
say it's a roadmap for leaving the left
I want people to understand that if you
want low taxes if you believe in borders
if you believe in an American context
the Second Amendment but certainly also
the First Amendment if you believe in
free speech if you believe in the right
to assemble all of these things these
are these are beautiful things that for
some reason if you talk about them and
don't follow every other piece of
leftist dogma
you you are you are out you are racist
you are bigoted you are all those
horrible things and that has cowed quite
literally millions and millions of good
people into silence there are I mean the
amount of email I get from people who
are my
I mean the most moderate but might have
some perhaps a personally traditional
view of marriage or might be for low
taxes so here's like the best example I
can give you so if you I find this one
all the time I I speak in a lot of
libertarian events and libertarians will
come up to me and say you know Dave I'm
afraid of saying in college that I'm a
libertarian because people will say I'm
racist and it's like well what what does
that mean how did late racist and
libertarian get confused and the reason
is if you say you're for low taxes what
a lefty will say to you is you're for
low taxes that means you hate poor
people and if you hate poor people that
means you hate black people and if you
hate black people you're racist now
first off you can tell them that well
actually there are more poor white
people than poor black people I mean
that's just the fact they won't care
about that and you can also then say to
them you know a lot of our programs that
are supposed to help poor people
actually hurt poor people which is why
the black community has been so hampered
by these handouts in an America American
context instead of help all of these
things and people don't want to be
called all of these horrible things so
what I've tried to do here is lay out a
road map you are going to be called
horrible things there is a chance people
will come for your job the media might
do a hit piece on you you have no idea
the ensuing chaos but if you are a free
person living in a free society and you
refuse to stand up for what you believe
in you refuse to say what you believe in
well then you get whatever's coming to
you you deserve whatever is coming to
you and I don't think most people want
to live like that and by the way I'm
pretty hopeful right now because you
know with Corona one of the things
that's happening is the online
conversation and the mainstream
conversation really are converging into
one thing we're watching CNN anchors now
and I'm sure you guys are doing it with
Sky anchors and everything else that are
basically broadcasting out of their
kitchens and once you see them without
all the makeup without all the fancy
lighting without all the teleprompters
and everything else and then you see the
average guy on YouTube who is just
sharing his thoughts which I would say
is something you know close to what I've
been doing you go holy cow these people
really are equal and if anything maybe
this guy even even knows more so there's
been a democratization of news right now
so I'm very hopeful that people can
start breaking out of this stuff and
that the road map as I say in the book
it's like
if I give you the roadmap here and then
you come out and you're not with me on
every one of those issues you don't
believe exactly what I believe about
abortion or you don't believe exactly
what I believe about gun rights or
whatever else but we basically broadly
agree on freedom there were a good shake
did you see the most recent Eric
Weinstein on on Joe Rogan I saw like
tiny little clips of it you've been
pretty busy right here it's one it's one
of those ones you probably need to
dedicate a little bit of time to but he
talked about this specifically to do
with how what is mainstream media now
what we classing is mainstream media
what you could call NBC and ABC and BBC
and Sky News and stuff like that is
traditional media but if we put this
video up and this video gets 20 million
views which would be great but if this
we put this video up and it gets 20
million views or Joe Rogan puts an
episode up and it gets 20 million views
and Sky News puts recording up and it
gets 1 million views whose mainstream
media like that's just a term we're
talking again about grandfathered in
from the old world because previously
being on a network was a signal it was
singing it was a sign of virtue of an
integrity of production quality of
research of all the rest of this stuff
and as you said before with Bill Maher
and increasingly now with a lot of news
shows the fact that you've got to squash
it into 3 minutes and 43 seconds before
the next ad break comes in and what we
need to cut to John who's in the parking
lot talking about this going on now all
that sort of stuff the fact that you
have these constrictions on it
inherently means that the quality is
going to be lower because you chopping
it up into like even believably tiny
little bits and yeah I thought that was
that was really a really really
interesting discussion from those two
guys and I want to say something else as
well about what you just brought up
which was did with Murray mentioned this
he said that people who don't take
ideologies wholesale and take them
piecemeal are going to be the immediate
targets for anybody on both sides and
the reason he said this was the case was
that anything which seems not to fit
the prescript in the prescribed bill for
whatever the particular stance is that
you're taking let's say that you have
conservative views on most things but a
progressive view on abortion or pick
your little way of piecing it together
says the nuance and the individuality
gets seen as the other side is weakness
it gets seasonal that's the weak point
that's the Achilles heel that shows that
you actually don't know what you're
talking about because you're supposed to
you Dave Rubin because you did your for
gay marriage you are not supposed to do
this with with taxes and you're not
supposed to do this with whatever yeah
so there's a lot there so I would say
broadly I agree with with Douglass's
prescription there but I would add one
thing which is that it's not exactly
equal so on the right generally speaking
on the right if you're a conservative if
you're a libertarian a classical liberal
you're allowed to agree to disagree
I mean I am pro-choice I talked about it
in the book I'm progressing lis
pro-choice that is one of the ones that
for conservatives is like me biggest
nono that that more than anything else
is like the one that they view as like
the one that they cannot budge on except
I am welcomed to their discussions all
the time to have that debate they're not
all thrilled with gay marriage but I am
welcomed to have that discussion I am
against the death penalty most
conservatives are for it I am welcome to
have that debate now try to do the
version of that on the other side
there's almost none of that where if you
pick one try to imagine someone that's
on the Left that's pro-life they've made
a point now Democratic politicians make
a point of saying it all the time
there's no room for you if you're a
pro-life to be a Democrat to be a lefty
if you don't take their position on
minimum wage as I just mentioned or you
don't absolutely sign up for the green
New Deal and believe exactly what they
believe on any given day that the
world's gonna end in twelve years as aoc
says and all this other stuff so the so
Douglass is absolutely right that the
bet the piecemeal person who's really
trying to do what you're supposed to do
as a human which is figure out how to
think and why you think what you think
which is exactly what this book is about
the piecemeal person is always gonna
take more fire because you have a more
complex system there and that complex
system is going to
have some some weaknesses sometimes
because it's a work in art right we
should we should apparently um
inherently suspicious of anybody who
once you know maybe two or three things
about their views you can then
extrapolate out the remainder well I
find that to be the most boring type of
person there is you know but again there
is an ability on peep for people on the
right at least right now I'm not saying
it is always like this but why is it
that I can go out for an afternoon drink
with Nigel Faraj and agreed it would
disagree on a bunch of stuff and we were
pretty drunk and we could disagree that
guy likes you know what why can I sit
with Donald Trump jr. and agree to
disagree why can I sit with Glenn Beck
or Dennis Prager or a million of those
other people and and there's virtually
no version of that on the left I'm not
saying that there are no good lefties
right so you can talk about the
Weinstein brothers or sam harris or a
couple people but I would say in effect
at this point if I mean I say this all
the time but defending my liberal
principles is becoming a conservative
position and that simply is true that is
what the new conservatives are about so
the left is just purging people and the
right is basically standing there and
saying join us and what I want to do is
I don't want to convince I don't have to
convince any conservatives that I'm more
right I'm not trying to make any
conservative more pro-choice I'm just
saying to the Conservatives hey guys
carve out a little space over here for
us because there's an because these guys
are bananas so give us a little room to
operate over here and a lot of cool
stuff can happen and by the way that's
happening already I get it um so this
links in why do Republicans or
conservatives get labeled as bad and why
did Democrats or labor voters get
labeled as good is it just signal yeah
yo its complete signalling I mean I have
a section on this I mean this this is
just factory setting thinking this is
just stuff that you get from the media
you get from culture it's like Democrat
good Republican bad Democrats care about
poor people Republicans care about money
Democrats are for peace Republicans are
for war you know the Democrats love gay
people Republicans hate gay people
there's a million of these
these nonsensical things and all that is
is factory settings that through culture
through state education through all
these things you just that is where we
all sort of baseline start government
good it's all the baseline stuff and
what your job is you know and I love the
phrase factory settings because it's
like when you get a television or a
computer you get a new MacBook what do
you do it comes with factory settings
and then what do you do you might make
it a little brighter you might change
your background you might have a
different sound do this or that it's
your job to modify your system to
something that you like and that's
that's what the way you behave with the
world should be as well so the only
reason that those things stick is
because unfortunately the the media has
sort of colluded I would say with the
Democrats or with the left to sell a
really dishonest meme and that meme is
that Republicans are all bad and in a
weird way or conservatives are all bad
and in a weird way this is donald
trump's greatest strength donald trump
saw it like the republicans tried it
with nice guys in retrospect i think
most people think john mccain was a nice
guy a decent human being
mitt romney a nice guy a decent human
being and guess what they both lost so
trump just said you know what I'm not
gonna play by these rules because it's
not just that as a Republican I have to
fight the Democrats that would be an
easy an even fight right there was just
Democrats versus Republicans battle it
out and to the winner goes the spoils
but what's really happening is it's the
Democrats and the media as this huge
monster versus the Republicans well that
you can never win so Trump just went in
and said well I'm just gonna blow up the
whole freaking thing and and that that's
why what I find what the people that I'm
often most frustrated with are these
these absolute never Trump errs because
I'm not saying I first time I didn't
even vote for Trump okay but I broadly
like his policies and I understand his
tactics and the idea that this guy's
Hitler or any of this other stuff it's
just nonsense what he's going in and
doing he's doing all the dirty work so
that the the good liberals and the good
conservatives can still go to their
parties and think that they're nice
people and then they [ __ ] on him for it
yeah I have a question are you a Nazi
dressed in the skin in clothes of a
Today Show correspondent ha ha
well that was a loose quote from a piece
in Der Spiegel where they had me on the
front cover of the whole thing saying
that I was the grand illusionist of the
alt-right and they had a very scary
picture of me I was sitting in my green
room where I have a an American flag and
I was sitting under the American flag
and that's really a an all right signal
and they said that you know the whole
article was written as if I was some
sort of like evil elitist they talked
about my Italian coffee maker which is
an espresso espresso coffee maker it
customer 140 pounds yeah hundred forty
bucks you get it at Walmart so but then
he you know he wrote and he has New
Yorker magazines on his walls yes I do
have one postcard from a New Yorker it's
I got it for $5 on the street in New
York City but the whole piece was a work
of fiction and the disappointing part is
that this guy who visited my home he
watched me do several shows he came to a
live event that I did that night at
University of Southern California he he
was the illusionist he decided to paint
me as this evil racist thing and and
just lie and fabricate and you know one
of the interesting things is I didn't
know this till after but there's a law
in Germany that if a publication is
gonna write about you they have to run
all of your quotes by them so this guy
spent literally all day with me from
about 8 a.m. to 8 p.m. in that piece and
Der Spiegel there's not one quote for me
because he would have had to have run in
mind so he so basically he spends all
day with me then writes a piece of
fiction and doesn't quote me once in the
entire thing even though I spent hours
talking to the guy so that's just I use
that example as just one of the many
ways we've watched the media collapse
journalists when I use air quotes are
the ones destroying journalism so unity
does this mean you'll not see adjacent
then Oh adjacent adjacent oh yeah yeah
which is 180 degrees actually yeah which
makes you adjacent adjacent oh my god
yeah congratulations how can we spot
fake news I want to know
well I loved writing this chapter
because I think it's it's sort of the
most functional in a way because we are
so manipulated by the news and as we're
all stuck right now at home with Corona
big tech which looms large over all of
us is now even bigger right we can't
congregate at a bar we can't go to a
political rally week we can't even go
out to dinner with our friends so big
tech which had all of this power over us
is now way bigger so I lay out several
types of fake news the one that I'll go
with for this is one of the pieces of
fake news or one of the aspects of fake
news that I think is the most insidious
is not just that they lie about stories
or that the headline is often very
different from the article or they
mislead you by cutting a quote in the
middle and the rest of it one type of
fake news is the stories that they won't
cover because it doesn't fit their
narrative so months and months go by
where mainstream just won't address a
story properly a good example of this
would be when Bret Weinstein who is the
professor at Evergreen University when
he was being attacked for being
anti-racist I mean he all he did was the
school had had put out a new eating that
white students should not come to campus
on a given day because to protest racism
they had always had this day where
students of color voluntarily decided
not to go to class and Brett was okay
with that but then on two years ago they
decided no on this day we're gonna
actually tell students not to come based
on the color of their skin he said no no
that's racist which we all know it is
racist of course and psychotic for a
university to tell a certain type of
student not to come to class I mean it's
actually mental this thing was blowing
up this story and then there were roving
gangs with bats trying to chase him off
campus and a whole bunch of other stuff
happening the New York Times just
refused to cover it
CNN refused to cover it that's a type of
fake news it didn't fit their narrative
that lefties are good and and the irony
is that Brett I don't know what he
describes himself now but he was a
progressive he was a lefty lefty lefty
Bernie supporting lefty so it's like he
wasn't even good enough for them but
that that really goes against the
narrative so the New York Times just
ignores it that in and of itself is the
type of fake news it's fake news by
omission
rather than by commission right yeah I
love that um you know who he needed in
that situation when everyone was roaming
around with baseball bats
Jack to Douglas Murray if he doesn't it
Jack Douglas Murray with him no one was
[ __ ] with Brett I like this idea of
Douglas Murray as a superhero he's I
know I know he was something that I was
surprised by again I'm politics isn't
sort of the tip of my spear for what I
usually get interested in although I've
got exposed to a fair bit especially
over the last few years it's difficult
to avoid I didn't know that nationalism
was classically liberal yeah well you
would ask explain how that works yeah
so I reference the book that I have
right here by your um Horizonte have
called the virtue of nationalism and and
I think you guys in the UK have a have a
particularly unique experience related
to nationalism because of everything
that your last you know for some odd
years were about related to Bragg's it
it is you're right it is me right I
would say of a nation to decide what its
borders are and to decide to defend
itself however it would like to and to
decide who can come when they can come
how many people can come in the rest of
it we see the simple truth is we're all
nationalists we just don't know it
I believe that America has a right to
defend itself to define its borders and
all those things Britons have decided
that it is your right to do the exact
same thing that you don't want to
outsource your decision-making to
bureaucrats in Brussels that's a
beautiful thing in my opinion that is a
beautiful thing you want to be governed
by the people you voted for not some
amorphous bureaucratic Commission that
isn't even within your borders right so
we are this is how this is how a society
can work in the most functional way
there's this idea that somehow the
global community must come together and
decide what is best but that's actually
deeply deeply dangerous because that
often removes the autonomy of each
individual nation what is the wallet of
nation-states
it's not if you just do that well
exactly what's the point of
nation-states now some people would say
well then we should have no border
I'm completely against that I want a
border United States has Canada to the
north we got Mexico to the south I like
that we have borders now that doesn't
mean we shouldn't let anyone in that
doesn't mean we should have no
immigration that certainly doesn't mean
we should be xenophobic or racist or the
rest of it what it means is we have
certain laws there are privileges it is
a freaking honor and and the most
spectacular privilege in the history of
the world to be an American citizen you
are the freest frickin thing that our
ancestors could never even imagine how
ridiculously free we are we can sit
around on tick-tock on our iPhones
talking about how oppressed we are in
the United States that is a that is a
beautiful denied freedom you need right
there yeah yeah that is all the freedom
you need right there so what you want is
you want every nation to decide what's
best for its citizens and then those
nations can come together and decide how
they want to work together on things so
it is a virtue to be nationalistic what
what unfortunately has happened here is
they've they've tricked a lot of good
people into thinking that somehow if
you're for your nation that you're a
racist so this would be why a lot of
brags of Tears were called racist this
would be a lot of why a lot of Trump
supporters are called racist and it
simply isn't true there is a reason you
have a lock on the front door of your
house that doesn't mean you hate
everyone on the outside but you're
allowed to protect your house I have a
fence and I have a lock on my house and
why would you treat your nation any any
differently than that I loved that that
point in the book really did sort of
drive it home for me I have to say is
someone who's British significantly
easier to talk about borders when you're
surrounded by water you know we just
have a quote we have a moat a 23-mile
moat around our country which makes it a
lot easier you know it makes it a lot
easier for those Australians to but but
how wants to go to Australia
no one's invading Australia this there's
nothing there in the middle there's just
a little bit around the edge and it's in
it's miles away from everything no one's
going on I know but those those beaches
are pretty sweet those beaches are
pretty sweet yeah you are you are
correct
um I want to hear I've got long welcome
all right I want you to tell us the
Cliff Notes version of when you got read
pilled
on your own show by Larry Aldo
this is just hilarious i mean larry
elder beat me senseless with fax and it
shouldn't be an x-rated r-rated and
floated on a pornhub shouldn't it yeah
yeah you definitely should have to click
your age i am 21 years old a yeah yeah
larry elder well what's interesting and
I write about this is that I I really
believe this that the best and worst
moment of my career were at the exact
same time that that's a pretty rare
thing for someone to be able to say what
happened was I had Larry elder on the
show at this point it was very early on
in my interviewing where I was mostly
having disaffected lefties so I had Sam
Harris on I had Maajid Nawaz on I had
Douglas morena Douglas is more of a
conservative but I think he has the
right sort of classically liberal lens I
had had people that were thought of as
pretty much moderates and not really on
the right really
larry elder was really the first guy
that i had in that position now larry
elder happens to be black that's all I
would say about his race actually this
is a guy who knows what he thinks he's
been fighting for what he believes in
forever and we sat down and I did what
lefties do I just said a couple things
because they sort of sounded right about
systemic racism and policing and all
these things and Larry beat me senseless
with that they resonate the red pill up
bludgeoned you over the head with it and
then full-si to deep throat I think
that's what it said in the book yeah
yeah exactly well you know I always say
to Candace Owens that I swallowed the
red pill and she snorted it he just he
just beat me with the red pill you know
just beat me into oblivion took took
whatever was left and reconstituted it
but the reason that that clip matters
and that clip has been clipped many
times and seen by millions and millions
of people is that when that interview
ended we were at a hora TV at the time
it was a bigger Network right you know
now I'm in my garage it's totally
independent and all that I had a whole
bunch of producers and directors there
and I walk into the green room I start
into the control room when it ended and
everybody was like Dave we're gonna cut
that don't worry about it we're not
gonna air that ba ba ba and I said no we
have to air that that was real I get I
don't come off great but if we don't air
that what is the point
of having a show about ideas what is the
point of conversing with people if we're
gonna add out edit out the meet we're
gonna edit out the moment that something
really happened and I think clearly my
instincts were right and when the video
went up and I suddenly saw all these
clips of it and everyone larry elder
destroys dave rubin and all the versions
of that that are possible it hurt at
first but it was pretty quick until i
started realizing that you know most
people were like whoa reuben took the
hit but you can see him evolving and
that moment allowed a lot of other
people to evolve
too so i'm actually very proud of it and
that's why I would say it's my best and
worst moment at the exact same time I
think you should be the the people who
hold on to their views and hold on to
being right
like their very being is on the line and
this is a Eckhart Tolle ISM where he
says that during discussions with
someone we have a fear of being proved
wrong because it's tantamount to
destruction of our ego and especially
from doing this podcast you will be
episode hundred and 60s somewhere in 160
s you know so having done this many
episodes I've been challenged a lot of
times not as hard or as deep as larry
elder did to you
which would be oh let me see what i can
do for it should be almost impossible um
but a number of times i've been i'm like
i am having to battle during a
conversation with either my position
being proved wrong or something which
inherently learning about armed
polyamorous relationships or non
monogamy and stuff like that which
justin has a visceral reaction from me
that makes me think that's challenging
and at the same time being sufficiently
cognizant of it to be able to go right i
can allow this some isn't that
interesting isn't it interesting that
i'm just getting completely dict on
camera by larry elder here isn't this a
wonderful situation kind of to be in you
know and i think no matter which side
you fall on in any discussion being able
to just take the argument on its own
merits and trying to remove that ego
from the situation firstly you're going
to feel so much less pain because it's
it's so much more enjoyable to go wow
and this is why i think that curiosity
is
one of this the most powerful
personality traits that you can have if
you're genuinely curious I was
interested to find out what you had to
say today I wanted to ask what it felt
like to get red pill by Larry ldren I
would ask what it did it all these
different stuff and if you're genuinely
curious about that it allows you to
transcend that ego it also breaks down
the barrier between you and that other
person right because they junk Dave's
here to find out he's here to upgrade
his own programming and I'm gonna keep
on pushing him and see how far I can get
oh actually I've gone too far he
actually has some facts about that he
can push back and that's what makes it
engaging you know as a listener and if
that's the case and if professional
conversation lists like you or larry
elder or whoever it might be if that's
the mode modus operandi that you're
following then presumably that's the
best way for everybody to discuss as
well so to bring this back to your first
question why did I dedicate this thing
to Ben Affleck
because Affleck did the reverse of
everything that you just said there
Affleck took a thoughtful moment where
where it could have been a teachable
moment this idea that we should be able
to criticize ideas and yet we don't want
to be bigoted towards people it's such a
fundamentally important concept and what
it asked like do with it you're gross
and racist and what does that do it
shuts down curiosity it shuts down
exchange it shuts down the ability for
people to have that beautiful dance you
know the only way you know how to map
reality you Chris versus me Dave right
now is that we're talking through these
wires right and it's like you can say
something and if you said something
completely insane and outlandish I can
now map my reality against that and push
back and hopefully I could say yeah I
could get you to go whoa maybe what I
said was bananas or or vice versa right
or you could say something wickedly
mind-blowing brilliant and I would go
thank you yeah yeah so please throw it
David try that we know you've done at
least eight of those mind-blowing you
dropped I'll take it so final thing
before we finish up um what have you
been most pleasantly surprised by so far
in 2020 it can be anything well what I'm
really surprised
well look everybody's surprised by
Corona and the fact that our world feels
up upside down so I'm not pleasantly
surprised by that what I am surprised by
in a pleasant sense I sort of referenced
earlier which is that so many of the
things that I talked about in this book
are suddenly things that are people that
people are talking about when I now see
lefties on Twitter fighting for states
rights I go man that is a great thing
and by the way what they're also doing
is have you noticed that identity
politics has been really dialed down
during this crisis because when there's
a real crisis when [ __ ] really hits the
fan
suddenly we don't have time for gender
pronoun conversations and we don't have
time for how many black people are on
this panel and how many white women are
on this and how many lesbians with a bad
knee and all that nonsense
so I'm pleasantly surprised that
identity politics has has been sort of
cooled off not destroyed but cooled off
and I'm pleasantly surprised that good
ideas states rights people really
realizing right now in America maybe I
should be allowed to protect myself
because our systems and our institutions
are shaky er than I thought I love the
idea that right now people that live in
big cities are suddenly going whoa is
this the best way to live is it the best
way to live in a you know you know
one-bedroom flat as you guys would call
it for five thousand dollars to live in
Manhattan when I could literally live on
50 acres in Montana how do I want to
work do I want to telecommute do I want
is this even the job that I want to be
at or or right now we're all trapped in
our houses and it's like am I married to
the right person do I like these people
that I'm in the house with did I raise a
good kid you know any of those things
I'm so inspired right now because all of
this tunnel
it's scary it feels like will the world
ever fully return I don't know that
it'll return I think we have a new
blazed a new trail to blaze but I'm
excited by the fertile ground right now
like everything's kind of messy and out
of a mess that's where beauty arrives
right like out of chaos is what that's
what makes great art that's what makes
great music and by the way we haven't
had a lot of great music lately we
haven't had a lot of great art lately
I'm not saying none of it and of course
it's smattered across the internet
but like there's a huge human
opportunity right now and I think people
like yourself people that are probably
listening to this people that have been
a little ahead of the curve and outside
of mainstream prolonged I'm like I think
our day is coming so let's grab it I
love it man yeah in an absence of a real
crisis we create our own and in the
presence of one we reset our values
that's how I'm looking at this situation
that's one of those brilliant things
just I just felt like I felt like I've
got the guy behind Rubin rapport and so
I just had to Mike drop it find a bit
you know I can't let you have the last
say actually actually I can why can
people check out your show in the book
and you online why should they go so you
can get the book at dumper in this book
com where we have a little brown books
is our UK distributor so it's uh you can
go to Amazon UK or wherever else you get
books and the show is youtube.com slash
Rubin report Rubin report comm
instagram.com slash Rubin report Ike my
Brandon guy's pretty solid so we're okay
I love it Dave man is been fantastic
hopefully we're gonna get through this
this next few months and I'm gonna
hassle you know I'm gonna get you back
on but thank you so much for your time
man you know what to do like share and
subscribe links to everything including
Dave's fantastic new book will be in the
show notes below if you've got any
questions or comments or you just want
to hassle us online go there as well
thank you talking to you and what do you
think should I shave the head - I think
not I think he got away with the top and
when you do you and Michael molly's go
through the hanbin it would absolutely
kill it let's do it listen the longer we
stay in quarantine I may have no choice
so we'll see cheers man thanks man
[Music]
you